what we're going to do in this video is
see that if we have two different
triangles where the corresponding sides
have the same measure so this orange
side has the same length as this orange
side this blue side has the same length
as this blue side this gray side has the
same length as this gray side then we
can deduce that these two triangles are
congruent to each other based on the
rigid transformation definition of
congruence and to show that we just have
to show that there's always a series of
rigid transformations that maps triangle
abc onto triangle e d f
so how do we do that well first of all
in other videos we showed that if we
have two line segments that have the
same measure they are congruent you can
map one two onto the other using rigid
transformations so let's do a series of
rigid transformations that maps a b onto
e d and you could imagine how to do that
you would translate point a you would
translate this entire left triangle so
that point a coincides with point e
and then
side a b would be moving in this would
be on this direction over here and then
you would rotate around this point right
over here you could call that a prime so
this is going to be equal to
a prime you rotate around that so that
side a b
coincides with side e d and we've talked
about that in other videos so at that
point
d would be equal to b prime the point to
which b is mapped
but the question is where is c if we can
show that for sure c is either at point
f or with another rigid transformation
we can get c to point f then we would
have completed our proof we would have
been able to show that with a series of
rigid transformations you can go from
this triangle or you can map this
triangle onto that triangle
and to think about where point c is this
is where this compass is going to be is
going to prove useful we know that point
c is exactly
this far away from point a i will
measure that with my compass so i could
do it this way as well
point c is exactly that far from
point a
and so that means that point c
needs to be
someplace
someplace on this curve
right over here on this arc that i'm
doing these are these are some of the
points that are
exactly that far away i can do a
complete circle but you see where this
is going
so point c i guess we could say c prime
or c will be mapped to some point on
that circle if you take it from a's
perspective because that's how far c is
from a but then we also know that c
is this far from b so let me adjust my
compass again
c is
that far from b
and so if b is mapped to this point this
is where b prime is
then c prime where c is mapped is going
to be someplace along this curve
and so you could view those two curves
as constraints so we know that c prime
has to sit on both of these curves so
it's either going to sit right over here
where f is and so if my rigid
transformation got us to a point where c
sits exactly where f is well then our
proof is complete we have we've come up
with a rigid transformation now another
possibility is when we do that
transformation c prime ends up right
over here
so what could we then do to continue to
transform rigidly so that c prime ends
up with f remember the other two points
of rd code have already coincided on
with e and d so we just have to get c
prime to coincide with f
well one way to think about it is
if we
if we think about it e point e
is equidistant to c prime and f
we see this
is going to be equal to is
we could put three hashtags there
because once again that defined the
radius of this arc
and we know that
point c prime in this case
point c prime in this case is the same
distance from d as as f is
as f is
and so one way to think about it imagine
a line between f and i could get let me
get my straight edge here so it looks a
little bit neater
imagine a line that connects
f and this c prime and once again we're
in the case where c prime immediately
didn't go to f where c prime ended up
being on
on this side so to speak
and you can see that
point e because it is equidistant to c
prime and f
it must sit on the perpendicular
bisector of the segment fc
same thing about point d or b prime this
must be the perpendicular bisector
because this point is equidistant to f
as it is to c s to c prime this point is
equidistant to f as it is to c prime the
set of points whose distance is equal to
f and c prime they will form the
perpendicular bisector of fc
so we know that this orange line is a
perpendicular bisector of fc
why is that helpful well that tells us
is if when we do that first
transformation to make a b coincide with
ef if c prime doesn't end up here and it
ends up there we just have to do one
more transformation we just have to do a
reflection about e d or about a prime b
prime however you want to view it about
this orange line and then c
will coincide with f because orange is a
perpendicular bisector so i could do
something like this
this length is the same as this length
and since it's perpendicular bisector
when you do the reflection c prime will
then coincide with f and a reflection is
a rigid transformation so we would be
all good